- I'm gonna start with this
'cause it seems like a crazy number.
25 million Instagram followers.
Is there pressure in that?
Do you feel like you have
to post at that point?
- Yeah, I definitely do feel that,
but I also give myself
the liberty to just, like,
not care that much.
- Good.
- I feel like I'm constantly like,
I probably shouldn't say this.
- It's like a whole separate job.
- I'm like, I like
continuously lose followers
every time I post.
So, I feel like I'm like,
all right, bye, I guess.
So I'm like, maybe it's better
if I just don't remind them
that they're following me,
and then-
- Just under the radar.
- Yeah.
- You're turning 30 soon.
Are you excited about this?
- I'm really excited to turn 30.
- [Kelly] Yeah?
- I'm like-
- [Kelly] 30s are fun.
- That's what I hear.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I just feel like your
30s, especially as a woman,
it's like really when
you come into yourself
and you like stop caring
about what other people think.
- Yeah.
- I feel like that's
already coming for me.
And you know, with "Riverdale"
ending after seven years,
I'm like, this feels like
a really great time to be turning 30.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- It's like a new chapter.
- I'm excited for you. I loved my 30s.
That was fun.
How do you celebrate? You
go big or do you chill?
- I like to have, I'm very social.
I like to have, like, everyone
gather for my birthday.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I really wanna have
a bounce house birthday
for my 30s.
- I love you. What?
I love that.
- I wanna just like get a big bounce house
and invite everyone and have
like, you know, a themed,
like a kid's themed birthday,
maybe like, you know.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Some Disney character as,
like, my cake or something.
- Have a petting zoo, have a whole-
- [Camila] Yeah, exactly.
- I will tell you during
COVID, like it saved us.
I ordered on, thank you, Amazon.
I ordered a bounce house
'cause my kids were going nuts
and, like, we were just
doing homeschooling
and all that stuff with COVID.
- [Camila] So, wanna get
these guys a bounce house.
- The bounce house saved us,
so I applaud a bounce house move.
- You were just on the
bounce house every day.
- It, yeah, just go get that energy out.
- It was for you, Kelly.
- And get out of the house. Yeah, yeah.
Well the new movie,
it's called "Upgraded."
- [Camila] Yeah.
- You seem very cute and very
sarcastic and funny in it.
- [Camila] Thank you.
- Do you like this?
Is it a rom-com? I'm assuming.
- It's a rom-com.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- Yeah.
- I love that.
- [Camila] I love rom-coms.
- They won't make those enough anymore.
- [Camila] I know.
- Yeah.
- I feel like there's a
new wave of rom-coms coming
that I'm really excited about.
- [Kelly] I am very for this movement.
- Yeah.
Do you like, did you like doing the film?
Did you know right off the bat you
were gonna be excited about the script?
- Yeah, I mean it's
like, I don't wanna say
it's "Devil Wears Prada" esque
because I feel like then
people have those expectations,
and that's an iconic movie.
- Yeah.
- But it does feel like a version of it
that exists in the art world.
And I think that really appealed to me.
You know, playing an up
and coming assistant.
There's Marisa Tomei shaving her legs.
- [Kelly] I love her.
- Which was her choice
by the way. She just-
- [Kelly] Of course.
- Decided that
and I was like, that's brilliant.
- Oh my God. So who is your character?
Who do you play?
- I play Anna Santos, who's an intern
for an art auctioning house
in New York called Irwin's.
And she gets invited to go to London
with her boss to be her assistant.
And she meets Will on the plane,
who we just saw in the clip.
And he mistakes her
and thinks that she's
claiming to be her boss
and she just kind of
goes along with the lie.
- Yeah. Are you good at lying?
Are you one of those people that's good?
Well, you're an actor so-
- I'm, yeah, but funny enough,
I think actors are worse
at lying sometimes.
- Or that's what you tell us.
- 'Cause acting-
(audience laughs)
Acting is living truthfully, you know?
- [Kelly] Totally.
- Under imaginary circumstances.
- Yeah.
- I just don't know how to lie well.
- [Kelly] I start sweating.
- Yeah, no, I-
- Even if I say something
to my friend, I'll be like,
you know what?
That wasn't true.
- [Camila] Yeah.
- And I'll out myself. Yeah.
- I feel the need to
correct myself about things
I really don't need to correct myself on.
- [Kelly] Like I'm gonna
go to hell or something.
- Like to the very T.
- Yeah. Yeah.
- [Camila] You know?
- I think that fear of God.
- I'm just kidding. I didn't
have an omelet for breakfast.
I had a burrito. I'm so sorry.
- It was actually, yeah,
I was gonna get the omelet
and then I decided so
that's why I said omelet.
Yeah, that's totally me, as well.
- And then you're just
like vomiting details
no one cares about.
- No one cares about. Yep.
That is me as, we're very similar on that.
- Yeah.
- Oh my God.
What's like a, what's a project
that you would love to do?
Like what's something in the acting world
- I would love, have
you seen "Poor Things?"
- No. What's that?
- I would love to work
with Yorgos Lanthimos.
- [Kelly] Okay.
- Like, he is a brilliant director.
- [Kelly] "Poor Things."
- Like, it's a masterpiece.
I would love to be in
like a really absurd,
surreal movie like that.
- Oh, thank you for the tip,
too. I'm gonna go watch it.
Yeah.
- [Camila] It's Emma Stone.
She's amazing.
- Oh, that's amazing.
Oh, I love her.
- Yeah.
- Oh, I know what you're talking about.
I haven't seen it. Yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay. That's awesome.
- [Camila] It's really fun.
- Project it. Put it out there, all right.
- Yorgos.
(audience laughs and applauds)
- Listen.
Let's do another short
commercial break, everybody.
You can see Camila in "Upgraded"
starting tomorrow on Prime Video.
She's also in the Prime
Video movie "Musica,"
which premieres April 4th.